mr. Hancock thanks for joining us on the
program this morning talk to us about
this app a lot of people worry about
privacy well it's not just an app it's a
whole system that we're launching of
test and track and trace the idea is to
be able to trace the virus to find out
when somebody has the virus to find out
who they might have passed it on to and
to be able to trace the virus so that we
can then defeat it ultimately and slow
the spread and that involves a
combination of the testing capability
that we've built up in recent weeks and
the technology to be able for your your
phone to be able to work out who you've
been nearby and also contact tracers and
clinicians and other people who are
there too so that when somebody tests
positive you get in contact with them
and you say who have you been near who
you might have spread it spread it to
and then you can tell them that they are
at at risk so it's a whole program of
tests and trace and the app is an
important part of that yeah but but
people don't want necessarily everyone
to know where they are no and of course
and and the app doesn't it doesn't tell
people where you are so they're all yeah
this has been designed with privacy
concerns built in but the critical thing
about it is that by downloading the app
you are helping to trace the virus and
to save lives so I'm really glad that in
the early surveys yesterday in the Isle
of Wight people were very enthusiastic
about downloading it that is what we
expected because people know that it's
it's really really important that we
trace this virus and and because that
that does save lives and and you know
these privacy concerns are involved now
and the built into the app but the
critical thing is all of us are having
to and you know the the liberties as a
nation that we're having to give up in
order to tackle this virus are already
enormous and so we're asking people to
do this because it will help us and
the virus with fewer of the big social
distancing
I wouldn't we could keep it short and
sweet today because I know we you're on
the show tomorrow or at 10 o'clock
tomorrow here on Sky News got lots of
time to put lots of questions to you
then let me just race through these this
morning if I may you need people to sign
up 50 to 60 percent rate in order for
this to work why are you saying no
thanks when people like Apple and Google
are prepared to help we they we need as
many people as possible to sign up
there's value to it if fewer people sign
up we've been working with Apple and
Google and the the reason that we're
doing it the way we are is because we'll
also then be able to spot flare-ups in
the app right across the country
so that's a that's an important feature
of it because when you have symptoms you
go and put them into the app and we'll
be able to spot where the flow why not
get Apple and Google involved when
they're saying you know we can help you
with this well we have been working with
them but their the the proposal they've
got doesn't have that capability and so
it doesn't help us as much as the as
what we're bringing forward okay let's
let's move on to the T you see saying
when people go back to work not all
employers will offer safe work space
what sanctions will the government put
in place if employers do not offer safe
+ safe workplaces for workers well look
it's critical that employers offer safe
workplaces and we've been working with
employers large and small and with the
trade unions on getting these details
right I know there's further discussions
going on this week so that as and when
more people can get back to work there
are the rare there's guidelines there's
rules in place to make sure that
workplaces can offer can offer it can
have safe distancing and social
distancing in the workplace like many
many already do like for instance you
know I might normally come in to the
studio to have this interview and
instead we're doing it over Skype and I
know what sanctions if people don't if
employers don't keep their workers safe
well they're artists
doesn't say about those and there's a
draft set of proposals but I don't want
to prejudge those discussions that Alok
Sharma is leading with well there's
there's already and there's already
rules in place that we've that we've
brought into to deal with the crisis yes
and it's about how we make sure that the
rules that exist and the guidance that
exists both works practically on the
ground for employers and also keeps
people say and what about employees who
still feel that they're not safe and
don't want to go to work they could lose
their jobs couldn't the government can't
protect them in that regard well we can
protect people by having the rules in
place or social distancing at work and
people doing the very best they can to
follow those rules and that's a you know
these are really important discussions
that are going on about how we can make
that work in practice because you know
that people do need to get back to work
because the economy is vital for for so
many things and including funding public
services so it is important but it's got
to be done in a safe way it's got to be
done in a safe way and something has to
give as far as the furlough scheme is
concerned I just read an article that
said that as a country we're paying half
the wages of the nation at the moment do
you think that furlough will be extended
if what next time you have a chance with
reishi soon at what are you going to say
to him well Ritchie was clear yesterday
that there won't be a cliff edge but as
you say we also need to get people
safely back to work so that we can so
that we can withdraw from that scheme
it's been very very successful in
keeping frankly keeping keep putting
jobs there keeping people employed in
keeping firms alive during this
incredibly difficult period but we've
also got to wean off it as the economy
gets back it gets back on its feet
it is a really difficult balance it's
something that I'm I know rich working
very hard on he was very clear yesterday
that there won't be a cliff edge and I
think that's that I think that's very
important why have you changed your mind
on the advice to over 70s about staying
at home we haven't we published the
advice several weeks ago and that is
that remains the advice yeah but you did
tell them that they should be staying at
home didn't you well the advice of the
over 70s we set out in detail on the NHS
website when the social distancing rules
were brought in and that advice remains
exactly the same now I know there has
been some some media debate about this
in the last couple of days but there but
the rules haven't changed and they're
really clearly set out there are
essentially three groups of people the
first group is the those who are and
clinically extremely vulnerable they
have a specific condition means that
they're very they're very susceptible to
this via to being ill if they catch the
ups we call them the shielded and they
just I know that we're sort of tight on
time so forgive me for interrupting but
you know the government said clinically
vulnerable people item six clinically
vulnerable people are those who are age
70 or older regardless of medical
condition it's okay to change your mind
but I just wondered why you had I
haven't and if you'll forgive me I'll
continue answering the question because
I was just about to come onto that day
the second group the second group is the
those who are clinically vulnerable
because the nature of this disease
including the over seventies and so and
others but some conditions for whom we
say they must pay they should pay
particular regard to the social
distancing rules because of that
vulnerability and then there's the rest
of us the so there are three groups and
we have a different set of a different
strength of advice for the three
different groups we set that out from
the start and and I'm glad to have had
the opportunity to set that out again
for you it's worth going
reading the NHS UK website about this k
because it's really important to get
right and not to confuse people because
I do people who are over 70 to be to be
confused by the media between the group
the first group I describe okay well I
thought I had read it meticulously I'll
go back and have a look at it again
ahead of tomorrow meantime are you gonna
be wearing a mask anytime soon well the
again on that the government guidance
has not changed we were constantly
reviewing the scientific evidence and
the scientists say that the evidence one
way or the other on the wearing of masks
outside of social health and social care
settings and some other particular
settings that evidence is weak one way
or the other but we'll keep it under
review quick thought on brexit before we
let you go I know that we're almost out
of time why don't we put these trade
talks on hold for a bit you know we are
a bit busy as a as a world at the moment
yeah but we don't need to so gosh it's a
while since I've discussed breaks out of
one of these programs there's absolutely
no need to I think you know we can the
basis of the future arrangement is
already set we can get the details in
place there's no reason to delay I think
we should just get on with it
but honestly it isn't something that I'm
spending any time on personally at the
moment because we've got this
coronavirus to deal with but it doesn't
need any time because we've got the
basis of the agreement so let's get on
and implement it we have had thousands
and thousands and thousands of questions
for you for tomorrow ask the health
secretary clock Sky News we don't have
time to ask all of them boy why do you
think it's so important to take
questions directly from the public well
I do I think it's really important
because you know there's so much about
this virus that's new there's so much
about the circumstances we're living in
that's new and you know my colleagues
and I are taking big decisions every day
about how we manage our way through it
and we take the best decisions we
possibly can but we also want to hear
from you and your
you know the viewers of this program and
so whether it's at the daily press
conference with now questions both from
the media and members of the public also
online ID I do ask me anything sessions
but and and I think I think we'll I hope
we have a really good session tomorrow
with questions from the public because
you know the the public as you say I've
got so many questions and totally
understandable and I want to be as open
and transparent as a possibly can be